[Music]
chuck i'm back yes
[Laughter]
i got some more explain
explaining to you explaining to do some
explaining to do
so this one is is a phenomenon that we
all know intuitively even if you didn't
know what it was called or that it had
full mathematical derivation for it
okay and it's called the doppler effect
yeah and chris john doppler i think was
a german uh scientist in the 19th
century first half of the 19th century
and he noted uh you know by the way when
when you're building the railroad okay
uh you can
there are new kinds of experiments you
can do
all right because a slow moving sort of
horse
and carriage
you're not thinking of the doppler
effect okay
right
but when you have a train that's the
clip-clop effect there's a clip clip
so when you have a train it's like wow
this thing is moving fast and it's
making a noise
oh my gosh what can i notice and what he
noticed was that trains these were
locomotives which make sound
the trains that were coming towards him
at whatever speed they were
had a higher pitched sound
than that same train receding from him
right
okay
and
he sought to figure out what that was
and why
and it's a very simple formula now that
says
that says how fast is the thing moving
towards you
plug it in and we'll tell you exactly
how much the frequency has changed
wow it's that simple that's great
think of sound as as waves that are
emanated right the crests the crest of a
wave so the train emits a sound and
there's a crest and here it is moving
towards you
at what speed
what do you mean what speed at the speed
of sound
oh
okay so now watch so that's the crest
that hits you but by the time
it makes its next crest
the train is closer to you
so the distance between those two
consecutive crests is shorter
than it otherwise would be if the train
was stationary you're getting a a a
crest crunch a crest crunch sure and and
and the opposite is happening as it
moves away it moves away there's a crest
of of sound that comes to you the next
crest is farther apart you know you got
a crest stretch you gotta correct
stretch so it's shrunken it's shrinking
up front and stretching out the at the
out the back and so that changes the
frequency of the sound
you get higher pitch coming towards you
lower pitch moving away from it has
nothing to do with the distance from you
it only has to do with the speed right
pure and simple and so as it's making
sounds when the train is right in front
of you
right in front of you it is making the
sound that is native to what the engine
makes
okay because as it's passing right in
front of you it's not getting closer to
you and it's not getting farther away
right
okay
the distance is not changing right in
that moment
so
this this is true for anything that's
coming towards you and moving away so uh
if you ever walked up to the edge of a
uh freeway
okay
the cars come one way and go come out
the other side here's the sound they
make ready
[Music]
yes
okay okay and they don't go they don't
go
[Music]
no they go no
that is so natural
but who stops to think about that
why should a car sound different coming
towards you than going away from you
it's the same car
so it's the sound of the tires on the
road and the engine and the
an air on the on the
say fuselage um air on the body of the
car all that makes sound and whatever
that is is going to be higher frequency
coming towards you than moving away
period that's very cool
now
before you go any further
clearly you have not seen
one of the funniest memes on the
internet
which is you
making that sound
and
somebody um
somebody injects that that image of you
going you
and
they started off with
um a sign being blown off by the wind
then you go yeah
and then the sign ends up hitting a
weather person no is that right okay
it seems to me you could put that on
practically anything right it's i gotta
tell you okay
but it's really funny i i gotta admit
it's a super popular meme on the
internet i'm telling you now here's
here's here's for me an interesting fact
uh when i visited my first and only
nascar race it was at daytona
and i was ready to hear the cars go no
but then i realized
no
they have microphones
all around the track
and the microphones then come through
speakers so you're not only hearing
the car
that's physically there going around the
track you're hearing the microphones
pick up the car sound and then deliver
it to you and since the microphones are
not coordinated in any way it's just one
sound of the car and i was so
disappointed
right they scrambled the sounds yeah so
so we lost the opportunity to do the
doppler shift experiment and i was
sitting next to a whole bunch of people
i wanted to be like educator physicist
and tell them all about it and i
couldn't yeah because just simply
because they sometimes
they kill doppler by by
but if you watch it on tv it's still
there because it's just one camera and
one camera catching it
yeah yeah yeah yeah so so that's it and
it works for any wave
so it'll work for sound i mean
it'll work for light waves
so if you have a light wave that's
let's say naturally red okay
and it's coming
towards you
red light has longer waves
than
blue light does so depending on how fast
it's moving you will shift
the spectrum of light
from red down the spectrum through the
orange yellow green blue violet and if
it's moving fast enough it'll go into
the ultraviolet and end up becoming
invisible to you for example if it's
just one sort of signature of light that
started out as red and it can go the
opposite way it could start it red
and if it's moving away from you it
could shift out of the red and go into
the infrared
or it could shift out of the ultraviolet
into the visible part of the spectrum so
the whole thing can shift just for being
in motion
wow
the doppler effect the dot so that is
the doppler shift that is the doppler
shift that's correct cool that's so now
i don't want to see him stupid but it's
already too late for that
okay go on so when we recognize the
doppler shift what do we learn from
observing that
like what signature what did you learn
yeah we learned whether to give you a
speeding ticket
okay the cops with their radar gun
they're using microwave frequencies
to bounce off of your car
and that bounce
captures the speed of your car at the
moment changing the frequency of the
microwaves
okay and so the gun notes what frequency
it's sent back sent to you
you're reflecting a different frequency
back it takes the difference in those
frequencies pops it into the
doppler's equation and then you get your
ticket and that's how you wow so chuck
here's an interesting fact
the police when they use their radar gun
right in order to get the most accurate
measurement for you
they need to stand
in the road facing you as you approach
them
because that would be the actual speed
of your car
if they are off to the side of the road
right then not all of your car's motion
is towards the radar gun right
only some of it
okay right that's if you do the vector
diagram that's how that works
so the point is and since the cop is
never exactly in the middle of the road
right if they catch your ass speeding
from the side of the road and hand you a
ticket for a speed you know you were
doing faster speeds than that well
absolutely and the reason why i know
what you said is right
is because the guns are calibrated for
that difference
because i got a ticket that was so much
money that the lawyer
basically said well here's the thing
um the
guns are not truly accurate
so you they have to be calibrated for
these pro specific and you can ask for
the calibration and maybe if they don't
have it you might be able to get off
okay so i read that about how to get off
from
for frap yeah
it doesn't work i read that as one of
the no but that calibration has nothing
to do with the angle that i'm describing
okay okay it has to do with just it's
just the gun itself circuit inner
workings of the gun okay the inner
workings of the gun so if so if they
measure you
any place other than standing in the
middle of the road
they will get a speed for you that is
less than the actual speed of the car so
if you earned your ass a ticket
for having less than the actual speed of
the car you really don't then you got no
case well you know
i can't no see i can't say it i was
gonna say that's why you're just
supposed to keep going you know it's a
real oh yeah that works
yeah yes you said the black man
understand the thing yeah
yeah
yeah
let's everyone take chuck's advice on
this one guys make sure you're in a
white bronco when you do it
one other thing
their radar gun depends on the signal
that gets reflected back to you back to
them okay right oh if if you have
if you have radar absorbent
car material right
then they can fire the gun at you and no
signal comes back to them no matter what
speed you're you're driving and if you
have radar absorbent car material you're
elon musk
so you can afford to pay the ticket
anyway and anyway anyway
so then
when they say doppler radar they must be
using radio waves to
measure the movement of the storm front
that's coming at you yes correct correct
doppler radar is you know i think
they're just i remember when that term
came into parlance of
the meteorologist right so doppler
radars they're sending radio waves in
getting the reflection back and they'll
know things like this generally that you
use that when there's stuff in the air
like right water water droplets storm
systems rain rain so you'll know exactly
how fast the rain is coming we have
other ways of knowing wind speeds now
but i think the concept of doppler radar
sounded cool and so they kept it but
you're not going to bounce
radar off of free air right that's not
that doesn't work you're not going to
okay you're not going to radar track a
low pressure system
exactly right unless the low pressure
carries water water right right
often they do actually uh that's the
change in the yeah actually
high pressure because high pressure good
weather exact pressure's good weather
you know why it's good weather because
all clouds that want to go there get
pushed away by the high pressure
that's pretty fun it's literally true
just seriously the pressure i'm just
trying to be a clown a clown man just
trying to be a clown
you know
so yeah high pressure generally no
clouds low pressure all the clouds
collect for it so
um
so there you have it that's the doppler
shift now there's a there's an aspect of
this i'll add here just for for
it turns out the expansion of the
universe
creates a form of a doppler shift
it's actually a little it's called a
relativistic doppler shift okay but so
here's the here's the light moving
through the universe mining its own
business and the very fabric of space
and time stretches while it's moving
through the universe
so that gives it a longer wavelength
yeah okay so the cosmic expansion of the
universe
gives everything a shift to longer
wavelengths just from the expansion
that's pretty wild because i'm trying to
get a
a visual and what i'm seeing
is like
if you were rolling a ball of yarn that
had a
loop
you know like when you snap a rope
okay on a bed spread
but then you stretch the bed spread
the yarn which is gonna take it with it
it'll take it with it correct wow
correct or or it's just like taking
chalk and doing a wave on a rubber sheet
and then stretch the rubber strips oh
wow change
see i've made it very uh too involved
yeah
yarn and bed sheets and stuff i like i
like knitting in bed
okay so yeah so you've increased the so
the doppler shift of galaxies in the
expanding universe right
is all what we say redshifted to longer
wavelengths right okay right and that
term
has stuck even though if it's giving you
red light it'll shift away from red into
infrared so it's the catch basin for any
wavelength that has been increased and
since the farther away you are the
faster you're moving away from us
we were able to use your redshift
not only as a measure of how fast you're
moving but how far away you are
we also got it's synonymous one-to-one
correspond almost perfect one-to-one
correspondence with distance
so that's it it's an extra dose of
of um so in other words if the galaxy
were moving away from us
in the expanding universe both of those
effects would combine with each other
which is of uh that makes sense right
right yeah so that's why we in the
universe we don't really call it a
doppler shift we just call it the
redshirt shift and everything else is a
doppler shift what's coming towards you
what's moving away and by the way we're
we're going to have a collision a
titanic collision with the andromeda
galaxy in five or seven billion years
from now we're we are falling towards
each other we show a blue shift in our
light
towards each other you might say well
it's a galaxy how come it's not
expanding how come it's not a vegeta
it's close enough so that its speed
falling towards us is greater than the
expansion speed of the universe for
being so close
because the nearby things are not
expanding as fast as the far away things
there you go right and within a certain
distance if galaxies within a certain
distance of each other they their random
motion can override what the expansion
of the universe is and that's what we
have with andromeda and a few other
galaxies that's trippy man
it's totally trippy trippy okay chuck so
just for old time's sake here i go you
ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
the doppler effect
there you have it oh by the way and if
you want to listen for it listen it for
it on sirens and and fire engines and
things right that are actively making
noise as they come down the street
and it's you'll see it everywhere yeah
and it's just a fundamental part of what
you expect
the world to be
and when you see it and when you
interact with it so there you go chuck
the doppler shift i love it i was gonna
say you asked for it but you didn't i
handed it to you
[Laughter]
all right this has been another star
talk explainer neil degrasse tyson keep
looking up
[Music]
you